un nuevo sitio de redes sociales afirma
que su base de usuarios ha incrementado
en un promedio de 47% y este es un dato
importante y ha aumentado en un promedio
de 47 por ciento cada mes durante el
último año el número de nuevos usuarios
el primero de enero del año pasado era
de 50.000 ok entonces teníamos 50.000
usuarios el primero de enero ahora bien
nos preguntan cuál de las expresiones
siguientes da el número total de nuevos
usuarios en miles que se agregaron en el
mes n del año pasado donde n por
supuesto es un número entre 1 y 12 muy
bien entonces te invito como siempre a
que hagas una pausa que pienses cómo
resolver este problema para después
compararlo con cómo lo haremos todos
juntos entonces la forma en que voy a
abordar este problema va a ser de la
siguiente forma voy a hacer una tabla
por ejemplo que diga el mes cuántos
usuarios había al inicio del mes
cuántos se fueron y cuántos fueron
añadidos en ese mes y cuántos nos
quedaron al final del mes muy bien
entonces para eso voy a dejar todo este
espacio y si nos fijamos por ejemplo en
el mes 1 que se digamos de enero al 1º
de enero teníamos 50.000 verdad entonces
pongo 50 y quedamos que vamos a medirlo
en 1000 es muy bien ahora cuántos vamos
a agregar pues vamos a agregar el 47% de
los que teníamos al inicio del mes eso
es 50 x
0.47 muy bien que es el 47% cuantos voy
a tener al final pues si nos fijamos
tengo 50 más 50 por 0.47 o lo que es lo
mismo 50 aunque lo voy a poner con el
mismo color que sería 50 x
pero por 1.47 verdad aquí estaríamos
sumando el 1 de aquí es como si factor
izamos el 50 y tenemos 1 + punto 47 que
es 1.47 entonces déjenme seleccionar y
copiarlo para utilizar esta información
en el siguiente renglón que copiamos y
pegamos porque porque en el siguiente
caso vamos a iniciar con esto en el mes
2 pues vamos a iniciar con lo que
terminamos en el primer mes cuántos
vamos a agregar ahora pues vamos a
agregar justamente esto pero x punto 47
por x punto 47 verdad que es el 47% de
este número que era lo que teníamos al
inicio entonces qué es lo que nos queda
al final ahora tenemos 50 por 1 punto 47
más 50 por 1 punto 47 por 0.47 entonces
nuevamente podríamos factorizar el 50.1
por 1.47 verdad factor izamos eso y nos
queda multiplicando a 1
y 0.47 eso sería multiplicar por 1 punto
47 pero si nos damos cuenta aquí
podríamos simplemente juntar este 1.47
con este y ponerlo como que está elevado
al cuadrado entonces quizás ya te estás
dando una idea de cómo va a estar este
patrón qué tal que nos fijamos en el mes
3 ok entonces con cuanto empezamos pues
con 50
ok que era lo que teníamos 50 x 1.47
pero ahora va a estar elevado al
cuadrado verdad aquí muy bien cuántos
vamos a añadir
bueno pues vamos a añadir lo que
teníamos que era esto donde él 1.47 va
elevado al cuadrado y tenemos que
multiplicar por 0.47 0.47 que es otra
vez el 47% de lo que teníamos de los
usuarios que teníamos al inicio del mes
cuánto nos vuelve a dar esto pues esto
nos vuelve a dar 50 por 1.47 si lo
factor izamos aquí podemos factorizar
1.47 al cuadrado y luego multiplicamos
por 1.47 así que eso simplemente nos da
un 1.47
entonces cómo puedes ya tú incluir al
mes n vamos a tener
vamos a tener que al inicio se van a
tener 50 por 1.47 elevado a la a la n -1
verdad por ejemplo aquí era 1 cuando el
mes era el 2
aquí era elevado a la 0 por ejemplo
cuando el mes era 1 entonces si tenemos
el mes n estamos elevando a la n 1
finalmente cuántos vamos a añadir pues
vamos a añadir 50 x 1.47 elevado a la n
1 que multiplica a por ejemplo 0.47 otra
vez el 47% cuanto vamos a tener al final
pues vamos a tener 50 por 1.47 y ahora
va a estar elevado al a la n muy bien
perfecto entonces la pregunta ahora es
nos dicen cuál de las expresiones
siguientes del número total de nuevos
usuarios que se agregaron en el mes n
del año pasado entonces uno podría decir
bueno tomo este número de aquí que son
son 50 por 1.47 elevado a la n y le
restó
le restó lo que tenía al inicio que eran
50 verdad entonces tenemos que le
restamos 50 entonces uno puede ir a
estas opciones y darse cuenta que no se
encuentran ahí así que vamos a tener que
utilizar alguna otra forma de calcular
eso y lo más fácil es lo siguiente
fíjense si sumamos todo lo que añadimos
mes con mes si sumamos todo lo que
añadimos mes con mes entonces estamos en
realidad calculando todos los usuarios
que fueron añadidos hasta el mes n muy
bien entonces vamos a sumar todos estos
primero nos damos cuenta que podemos
factorizar un 50 así que podemos
factorizar 50
y también podemos factorizar un 0.47 por
ejemplo de aquí de aquí de aquí y de
aquí entonces factor hizo 0.47 también
factores del 50 muy bien y ahora
multiplicamos por quien multiplicamos
por en el primer caso sería 1 verdad 1
por 50 por 0.47 aquí quizás se ve como
un 6 pero en realidad es 50 muy bien eso
nos da lo que está en el primer mes
por ejemplo en el segundo si factor
izamos este y este nos queda 1.47 1.47
más si factor izamos 50.47 nos queda
1.47 al cuadrado y así sumamos todos
hasta el 1 punto 47 a la
y vamos a mover tantito esto
un poco más elevado a la cif
actualizamos el 50 y el punto 47 a la n
- 1 y podemos notar aquí en estas cuatro
opciones que es justamente la respuesta
de y ahí lo tienen ahí está la respuesta